hey this dr. Bergin in this video we're
going to talk about the anatomy of a
tumor so a lot of women are getting
these fibroids and general population
men women are getting polyps some people
get moles some people get pimples if you
look very closely in the mirror at your
face you may have all these little bumps
that are occurring and then they kind of
go away and they come and go and come
and go so there are a lot of things are
constantly changing in the body you have
over 60,000 genetic errors in your DNA
every single cell every single day so
you have all these things that are
growing and shrinking so your body is
constantly keeping these cells in check
and they're actually controlling the
cellular growth so it doesn't get out of
control and create tumors today I want
to talk about what's behind the scenes
there is one interesting thing that
occurs before you get a tumor or a
fibroid or a polyp and that is low
calcium now calcium is the main mineral
that controls all of the communication
in between the cells because you have
these things called calcium channels and
calcium carries nutrition and
information between the cells and that's
why a lot of people with low calcium
start to get all these issues with extra
cell growth but it's not just hello
calcium it's a lot of other factors but
I wanted to mention that what's but what
starts this process is a lack of
communication in the cell the cells
these tight junctions right beneath the
tumor they lose control and then your
body starts making more and more and
more cells and out of an out-of-control
fashion and it starts growing a tumor
and what happens is that this will occur
if the soil of your body the terrain of
the body is fertilized with these other
factors as well nutritional deficiencies
sugar did you know that cancer in and
tumors live on sugar and
fact they depend on sugar but we don't
have to worry about that because I know
you don't need trigger so even the PET
scans that monitor and screen for cancer
look for those cells that are eating up
all the sugar in the body that's how
they detect cancer so by not eating
sugar you can basically starve off these
these cancer cells stress stress will
set the person up for all sorts of
problems with the immune system and more
genetic defects chemicals you have
pesticides insecticides herbicides and
even chemicals and smoking chemicals in
our food I just found out that the the
binder that they feed a lot of chickens
are fed with formaldehyde yeah that's
right so what happens is these chemicals
create alterations in your DNA those are
called mutations so mutations are sudden
changes within this lifetime
there's sudden errors that go out of
control and they can alter your immune
protective DNA repair mechanism so now
we can't suppress the tumor anymore and
so it grows out of control and then you
have radiation now
chronic inflammation let's say you're
having a menstrual period every single
month while you're setting yourself up
for great growing tumors from that
terrible heavy crampy cycle so it really
is a combination of all these things but
it all starts with this calcium right
here so let's just kind of get into a
little bit more on this calcium first
because in order to transport the
calcium into the tissues you need
vitamin D and there's even a lot of
studies that show that vitamin D reduces
cancer simply because it will help you
regulate the calcium so the way it works
is vitamin D is absorbed in the
intestine by 20 times so that's the
purpose is to get a lot more absorption
into the small intestine so it can
combine with a certain protein and now
once it's connecting that protein and go
through the blood and it can transport
through the body
just straight calcium like if you take
calcium carbonate that urn most
supplements it does
do anything is like eating a rock it's
hard to absorb it's not transported so
you need vitamin D to break it down and
to get it absorbed into the blood so
vitamin D is very very important if we
take a look at the world and the equator
right in the center where there's a lot
of Sun there are very low rates of
cancer in this area of the world as you
go north in the colder weather is when
people don't get as much Sun there's
much greater higher incidence of cancer
and tumors
now exception Japanese women have low
rates of breast cancer and that is
because they eat a lot of fish which
have vitamin D and a lot of eel in their
sushi you don't eel has the most vitamin
D like three ounces is five thousand
international units of vitamin D it's
incredible so so we need vitamin D from
the Sun or a supplement always take
vitamin d3 and then we also need vitamin
F okay now what is vitamin A vitamin F
is another name for the omega-3 fatty
acids like in fish oil those are the
polyunsaturated fatty acids there are
omega-3 fatty acids and that's why fish
oil is also good for anti cancer because
it helps you absorb that calcium so we
have vitamin F transports calcium into
the tissues and then vitamin k2 and I've
done a video on this vitamin k2 drives
the calcium all the way into the bone
and it cleans up the arteries and it
helps you modal mobilize calcium through
the body and if you notice vitamin d3
vitamin F k2 those are all fat vitamins
so we need fat to mobilize calcium and
what are people telling you to avoid fat
there's also another vitamin that's very
essential for calcium and I forgot to
put that that's vitamin A yeah
and these vitamins vitamin D vitamin A
if you look them up control what's
called the differentiation of what cells
turn into so if you're for example
deficient in vitamin A you'll have all
this rough skin because the cells can't
be
duplicated exactly like they should so
again these vitamins are very very
important in the transportation of
minerals and the protection of tumors
now I just want to get into one more
thing and that would be the tumor cell
and the cancer cell will hijacked your
blood flow to because they need blood
they need oxygen in some cases to feed
that tumor and grow it and that's called
angiogenesis if you want to look that up
but that's basically the all these blood
vessels are started feeding the tumor
and the cancer and it just starts
growing out of control but what's
interesting is what will stop the
process of going from a benign to a
malignant tumor or cancer would be phyto
nutrients so there's a lot of studies
being done now on these vital nutrients
that would be all those great
cruciferous vegetables that you're
eating right now the kale those are
essential for the blockage of this blood
flow to the tumor and to cancer and
that's why phytonutrients are very
anti-cancer so those are some of the the
points and the highlights of tumors and
your skin with these little pimples and
then how your body is constantly trying
to counter this it's very very important
to keep the soil of your body the
terrain very help-help very healthy
through these factors right here so I
hope that kind of gave you some insights
on why people get tumors and why they
might not so apply this information and
I will see you in the next video